hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a classic game
spooky's jumpscare mansion also known as
spooky's house of jumpscares a new dlc
came out last year in october
the spooky month called the doll house i
already don't like it which means that
i'm probably going to like it um it's
been a long time since i played this
game
uh huh
shakedown
why would i want to shake the doll why
am i going to want to shoot
why am i gonna want to shake the doll it
has been a long time since i played this
game
so when it comes down to uh
you know
the whole
thing about it if you recall it's just
um
an endless series of hallways with which
there are jump scares inside of it
and they could pop up at any moment
and it's pseudo randomly generated
why why
why
the air here is heavy with must and mold
your lungs seem to struggle as you
inhale your ability to heal is hindered
in this place
i forgot that i had an ability to heal
at all
hi
i forgot i had that
okay
wow um
i don't think i want that
hello
[Music]
your spirit has been recorded
well that's good
it's locked yeah no joke
something about this doll draws you to
it pick up the doll sure
[Laughter]
is that just going to be there forever
now congratulations gl labs associate
you have been volunteered for a proud
parent program you have been given a
doll and your duty is to train the soul
entrapped within to confine it to the
doll you must keep it in good spirits
and give it attention many of the beta
candidates were children when they died
and will likely attach themselves to you
without problems but there may be times
when punishment or extraction of spirit
energy is necessary the energy can feel
quite replenishing but please refrain
from abuse as it negatively affects the
ghost
in the event of husk rejection or injury
jail labs is not responsible under any
circumstance
[Music]
wait there was something else wait hang
on hold on shut up shut up shut up
there's something else over here
ah
map picked up press m to use
oh interesting it's actually a level
oh great
good
good
good hello
are you melting oh
[Music]
oh
don't like any of this
all right
okay
the clock room okay the clock room is
usually an important thing in horror
games and looks like it is because
there's a
wire cutter
in there
why
this is always the early part in horror
games where i don't really know what's
going on what
i thought i saw a hand
shake
don't look at me
oh god i hate it
i hate everything about this
[Music]
okay
great
good
gel labs id 1863 log 23 we've made
progress but none of it has been ideal
we developed a system to summon and
contain these spirits however we've been
yet to be able to find a suitable
container when the director first
summoned his daughter back from the dead
we were astonished but she didn't stay
here long without something proper to
tether the spirits back to the earth
they simply fade away we tried simple
jars vases and the like at first but
these containers limited the functions
of the spirits we've had minor success
using humanoid vessels but the spirits
are still tied to the physical damage of
the containers and are thus too fragile
therefore
hello they're for a doll perfect
the piano room
of course
hi
hello
oh it sounds out of eh
well funny about that
west wing key picked up
good
great
i'll just be on my way then
[Music]
right okay
okay all right you don't need to tell me
twice
you don't need the
help
okay
i was a good girl all day long but when
dad got home he was all wrong so i hid
in my room until he was gone and when
then i shot him in the face at 5 45
his gun was so shiny sparkly in need and
his face was so mushy gushy squishy i
wanted to shoot more people but my mom
made me sleepy now i'm in this weird
house with all these weird white coat
people and they won't give me a gun
well
i don't want to know what that is
okay all right i'm leaving i'm assuming
that the west wing key goes
ah
here
unlocked great
okay good well this seems relatively
normal
for like an amnesia normal
what are those things
besides little baby demons
i'm trapped oh god hey you won't get me
oh no you won't get me there's something
in there ah
i'm leaving
[Music]
okay i'm just gonna go right by
those are fine
it's fine
we're having difficulty ow how do i i
wish i had my axe what if i put the doll
down oh no no no
yeah what if i go put the doll down
can i do that
put the doll down yes please i need to
kill some things okay good okay let's
try this again
you little shits
come at me bro
that's what i thought
that's what i thought
oh there's plenty of you
oh six unlimited stamina
that's what you get that's what you get
all right i can't go in there
yeah i don't know why i need to hold the
doll all the time but i have a funny
feeling
oh
interesting so they just
they come back up
aren't you horrible
quite horrible quite horrible i have to
say quite horrible
okay we're having difficulty containing
one of the stronger spirits the dolls
that we use to hold them keep stretching
out and breaking and then we have to
summon the spirit all over again
theoretically the size of the vessels
shouldn't matter but it complains that
it's all too small
so for now it's locked up behind an
emergency containment door
good
great
until you get back you do get back up
you get right back up
tea time oh
sit down
i'm guessing i need to have tea time
with my doll oh i could have come here
and pimp it pow
i could have put the doll down here
oh
well you suck hello dolly
hello dolly how are you
let me save dolly
great dolly
so i just need to blow past them so i
can have some goddamn tea time
man those guys
hello dolly
hi
do you like tea time
i like the time very much
tea room for proud parent volunteers
this room functions to relieve stress
and replenish spirit energy in the event
that the doll has lost potency you may
use this function by placing the doll
upon the pedestal and sitting across
from it in the event of husk rejection
or injury glass is not responsible under
any circumstance good luck proud parent
i don't know what husk rejection is
all right good good tea time anyway
let's go
let's go
oh
[Music]
oh this is the containment door
what
oh
i don't fit in this i can't stretch or
else i break and they did this to me
oh
hi
oh no
[Music]
where why
[Music]
how
okay okay okay okay it's right there
but i can't see it i'm gonna go now
there's a hole in the wall
yeah reached inside something grasped
your hand oh oh my oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god help help help help
no no
no shake shake no no
[Music]
well that's what i get for sticking my
hand in unfamiliar holes well
i haven't saved in a spell
and i deserve that
what should you expect
but to die when something like that
happens okay so let's carry on uh
going back to that room i think i need
to go get the key again
i'm gonna just grab this yoink and then
i'm gonna get the hell out of here
okay see i don't see you but i'm
trusting that you're there and i'm not
gonna reach my hand in any holes
not gonna do that
oh i don't like that oh i do not like
that i'm gonna do i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna do it
what was that
yeah i'm not gonna actually i'm not no
no the answer is always no
you see anything horribly suspicious
access card required what do you mean
oh god
okay what key did i get i don't even
remember what key i got
i wasn't paying attention
let's get some tea time in
huh
oh i see the spiritometer down there
okay so our spirits is good i thought it
said like west wing key but i already
whoa
why oh why
but i thought i already got the west
wing key
yeah i was in such a hurt oh hey uh-huh
yeah i was wondering where you were yeah
here i am
i had forgotten about this place
so many tortured souls are here uh-huh
well anyway i'm gonna go check on
something see you later
okay all right thanks
thank you go check on something why was
my dog crying when you were here
door's locked from the other side well i
don't really oh
hey
i unlocked it okay good good good good
good good
no okay i need to chop that open
ah that's what i need to do so i need to
put you down because that's why i needed
to do all that then i'm gonna chop it
open
ah
you shut up
okay good you shut up
um well that's suspicious
i'm gonna save i didn't save i'm gonna
save i know i just did all that for
nothing but i'm gonna save now
and then i go back and kill them all
again
okay and then i'm gonna
let's try this oh it slices through my
hand i did it again okay well that was
pointless
seems like i need some kind of a
something can i have you please
should i have some life please please
give me your spirit energy
can i
leave okay so i can't go to the garden
because there's
too much in the way there's a root
cellar over there and i got some kind of
a key but i don't remember what it was
because i was in such a hurry
the clock clock could it have been the
clock key it might have been the clocky
which would have
i don't like that room
there's really no reason why i shouldn't
like that room it's just that it clicks
but i don't like that room
clocky 5 45
5
45 oh
thank you
i'll take that
and now
i can open the wire
okay wires cut apart okay
here we is ooh great good i love a grave
why does this look like legend of zelda
oh no
dear monica although it was difficult
i've respected your wishes and let you
rest
i miss you every day i miss you so much
i'm still going to try to save our
daughter i know it's not what you wanted
but i've already gone too far she's so
close i just have to find a way to keep
her here i love you
blank
huh interesting interesting are you
crying is this doll crying is it is it
crying hello don't cry
it's all good it's all good baby
where am i uh
oh
okay
well i don't remember
okay so it's it's upside downy
i don't know why the map is laid out
like that
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy that looks like a
tesla gate the kind that you'd use to
stop old larry
radical larry that is i don't like that
i don't like that
i don't like that
i don't like that
oh boy here we go again
i haven't saved in a while but whatever
okay bye
oh boy oh boy
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh squeak
switch is locked in place so i need to
put something in the furnace
and i don't know what that is yet so
maybe i'll just maybe i'll go get some
more information and then i'll come back
here hi doll
how you doing okay clap clown
clown
clown
oh boy
oh boy oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
i haven't told anyone yet but i think
this place is haunted there are like
these strange wonding sounds all the
time like a moan but also a whoa you
know so woaning and there was this
painting that i kept staring at that i
think was
changing which painting was changing
was it this painting
was it this painting okay
all good here nothing weird about that
let's go to the clown
oh no oh why did you cover your eyes oh
no what's with the clown
oh no
oh no
i don't like the cloud
i don't like the cloud
oh i don't like to go keep the dolls
happy we created this party room we even
summoned his
spirit to entertain them
but this experiment failed miserably the
dolls hated here and seemed totally
freaked out around the clown i requested
the document on how it was found and
apparently they tried to summon a happy
human ghost but instead got something
else it looks human it acts humans but
just to be safe we install the cage just
what did they summon yeah good question
great question i don't like the clown
i'm just gonna go ahead and say that i
don't like the clown
guys i'm gonna say this straight up i
don't like the clown
bye bye
bye-bye ah markiplier fan of course okay
so
i don't exactly know what i'm supposed
to do over here
so i'm just gonna
what what happened what happened what
was that
what'd you do
nobody move
a doll is a timeless thing in a shape of
a human but created perfect immortal and
unmoving yet hollow devoid of soul a
fitting symbol and possibly usable
device for our goals here
soon i will have you back my dear but
first i must make sure it won't restrict
you
okay what is this
oh there are several broken doll parts
and a pair of plastic clasp hands that
appear to be holding something they're
slightly melted together pick it up sure
because why wouldn't i do that
i'm gonna put this in the furnace and
i'm gonna burn it
that's what i'm gonna do
but first maybe i should go save let me
go do that because i don't like this i
don't like this at all and i don't like
how long it's been since i saved
dude
you guys saw all the lumps right
where
oh my god why whoa whoa whoa what
[Music]
why why am i moving slow
pardon me why why is everything moving
slow now
what happened
oh we're fine
okay we're fine anyway i'm gonna pop
this in the furnace and i'm gonna
roasty toasted live
i think those lumps are supposed to be
the animate dolls
don't mind me
gonna go melt this thing
[Music]
let's pull this
no one minds this right
okay that was fine
got it all melted away revealing a small
metal key okay i have a key now
which i love ooh don't love that
i don't remember any small thing being
locked
uh oh the lumps have moved
the lumps are no longer great
good
what
oh hi
uh
i was thinking you might want some help
so i moved all those dolls out of the
way
well have fun
you moved all the dolls out of the way
you move them you move them all out of
the way to
maybe electric wall move move them yeah
you know um
yeah thanks for that um thank you for
that why did you need to do that
and why am i not trapped over here and
what do the keys go to and please don't
say it's to the clown because i really
am going to be upset if that's the case
but it seems like the only thing that it
could possibly be here for is
the clown okay
oh no oh no
oh no not the clown
oh no not the clown
oh no
oh no
okay so when the doll covers its eyes
i'm guessing that's gonna be bad so i'm
stuck here
oh
oh oh oh
oh
oh okay interesting don't know why that
happened
but that happened
okay at least i can go back and save
and then also the clown is somewhere
here with us now in this place
so i'm gonna go save
okay good okay good i have small keys i
don't remember what small keys are for
but i have them okay so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching this has
been
spooky's house of jumpscares really
creepy of creepy
don't really know what's going on but
i think it's gonna be pretty fun i'm
gonna play this one through just because
i am curious see where this is gonna go
i know spooky's house of jump scares was
like a slog of a thousand rooms so i got
a funny feeling that's to have me going
back and forth quite a while but it is
very fun so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always i will see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you